françaises français mes chers
compatriotes quand le 28 octobre dernier
je me suis adressé à vous je m'étais
engagé à vous rendre compte de
l'évolution de l'épidémie et des
décisions qui pouvaient être prises en
conséquence un mois plus tard où en
sommes nous le nombre de cas positifs
journalier à la coved 19 a fortement
reculé
il a été supérieur à 60 milles il s'est
établi la semaine dernière à vingt mille
cas par jour en moyenne
après avoir atteint 33 1500 patients
hospitalisés le 16 novembre soit plus
que lors de la première vague
nous avons aussi commencé une lente
décrue
le nombre de personnes en réanimation du
fait de lakovic 19 est passé de 4900 le
16 novembre à 4300 aujourd'hui de ces
données il ressort que le pic de la
seconde vague de l'épidémie est passé
lors de ma dernière intervention nous
redoutions des chiffres bien pire encore
et nous les avons évité
d'une part car nos efforts vos efforts
ont payé
l'esprit civique dont vous avez fait
preuve a été efficace et d'autre part
parce que nous avons appris à mieux
prendre en charge et traiter les
patients atteints pour éviter certaines
formes graves qui auraient frappé nos
concitoyens et peser encore plus sur nos
services de réanimation
je veux aussi saluer le dévouement des
soignants qui en ville comme à l'hôpital
ont tenu qu on perd et innover malgré la
fatigue et la lassitude je salue tous
les professionnels les associatifs les
bénévoles qui ont aussi ici aider c'est
tous ensemble que nous avons obtenu ces
résultats c'est tous ensemble que nous
avons sauvé des vies
si nous avons réussi à ralentir la
circulation du virus
nous ne devons pas perdre de vue nos
autres préoccupations sanitaires
il nous faut d'abord continuer de
traiter parfois de reprendre les soins
pour les autres patients il nous faut
aussi nous préparer à faire face aux
conséquences de long terme liés au virus
des scientifiques et des experts
travaille d'ores et déjà avec
l'assurance maladie un suivi de long
terme des malades de lakovic 19 je
demande aussi au gouvernement de
préparer une stratégie pour prendre en
compte les conséquences psychologiques
de la pandémie et des différents
confinement je sais en particulier
combien les personnes âgées à domicile
comme dans les maisons de retraite
combien les personnes en situation de
handicap ont souffert et souffre encore
de leur isolement et combien nous devons
les accompagner dans la durée
il nous faut enfin redoubler de
vigilance pour prévenir et répondre aux
violences faites aux femmes et aux
enfants durant cette période de
confinement certes donc nous avons
freiné la circulation du virus mais il
demeure très présent en france comme
dans tout l'hémisphère nord en europe
aux etats-unis au canada en russie où
ils circulent en encore très fortement
aujourd'hui nous avons atteint 50 mille
décès dus à l'épidémie
et si la situation s'améliore
globalement dans l'hexagone et dans nos
outre-mer dans certaines régions elle
demeure très préoccupante
nous avons encore devant nous plusieurs
semaines pour atteindre les objectifs
que j'avais fixé qui permettent de
contrôler l'épidémie est donc de
stabiliser le nombre de contaminations
autour de 5000 personnes par jour et
d'avoir entre 2500 à 3000 personnes en
lits de réanimation
aussi je m'adresse à vous ce soir pour
vous dire qu'il nous faut poursuivre nos
efforts
quelles sont nos objectifs sauver des
vies au maximum maîtriser l'épidémie
tout en prenant août à chaque fois au
mieux les autres malades
l'isolément de certains notre économie
l'éducation la culture le sport
notre art de vivre
adapter la réponse au territoire en
particulier pour nos outre mer ou des
plans spécifiques par territoire seront
prévues pour ce faire il nous faut
continuer pendant plusieurs semaines à
éviter nombre d'activités dans des lieux
clos qui accélère la diffusion du virus
et limiter au maximum les rassemblements
à partir de là je veux pouvoir ce soir
nous fixer un cap un calendrier esquissé
des perspectives une nouvelle étape
s'ouvrira à partir du samedi 28 novembre
matin il ya d'abord ce qui ne va pas
changer le confinement adapté et donc le
système de l'attestation resteront en
vigueur car c'est ce qui nous a permis
d'obtenir ces bons résultats
il faudra donc continuer à rester chez
soi à télétravailler quand cela est
possible à renoncer aux réunions privées
aux rassemblements familiaux et à tous
les déplacements non nécessaire mais dès
samedi prochain matin plusieurs
changements seront réalité d'abord les
déplacements pour motif de promenade
l'activité physique en extérieur seront
désormais permis dans un rayon de 20 km
et pour trois heures les activités
extrascolaires en plein air seront à
nouveau autorisée pour les cultes les
offices seront à nouveau permis dans la
stricte limite de 30 personnes enfin et
je sais combien l'attenté grande et
combien cela participe à notre quotidien
à la vie de nos centres villes de notre
centre bourg enfin donc tous les
commerces pourront rouvrir et les
services à domicile reprendre mais dans
le cadre d'un protocole sanitaires
strictes qui a été négocié avec
l'ensemble des professionnels que je
veux ici remerciés
les commerces et les services pourront
donc ouvrir selon ses règles jusqu'à 21h
au plus tard les librairies les
disquaires les bibliothèques et archives
pourront aussi rouvrir dans ces
conditions la deuxième étape ce sera le
15 décembre le 15 décembre
si nous sommes bien arrivés autour des
5000 contamination par jour et environ
2500 à 3000 personnes en réanimation
nous pourrons alors franchir un nouveau
cap
alors le confinement pourra être levée
nous pourrons donc à nouveau nous
déplacer sans autorisation y compris
entre régions et passer noël en famille
il faudra au maximum limité les
déplacements inutiles souffler et se
retrouver oui mais j'en appelle à votre
sens des responsabilités il ne s'agira
pas à coup sûr de vacances de noël comme
les autres
les activités extrascolaires en salle
pour l'accueil des enfants durant les
fêtes seront à nouveau autorisée avec
des règles strictes les salles de
cinémas les théâtres les musées pourront
reprendre leurs activités
toujours dans le cadre des protocoles
sanitaires qui ont été négociées et un
système de rodage permettra d'organiser
les représentations en fin de journée je
veux ici dire combien je remercie et
combien nous soutenons tous les acteurs
de la culture à qui je le sais nous
avons tant demandée mais qu'ils ont
tenue qui ont créé et innover su trouver
de nouveaux publics dans ce contexte si
difficile nous avons besoin de nos
concitoyens ont besoin en effet de
pouvoir avoir une vie
si je peux dire et des activités au
maximum et la culture est essentielle à
notre vie de citoyennes et de citoyens
libres des contraintes fortes
demeureront toutefois durant cette
période les grands rassemblements seront
interdits ainsi que tous les événements
festifs dans les salles à louer tous les
lieux qui comme les parcs d'attraction
les parcs d'exposition sont susceptibles
de rassembler un grand nombre de
personnes venant de régions différentes
resteront fermées de même les bars les
restaurants les discothèques ne pourrons
rouvrir leurs portes malheureusement
durant cette période
concernant les stations de sports
d'hiver une concertation a été engagée
par le gouvernement avec les élus locaux
et les professionnels
les décisions seront finalisés très
prochainement mais il me semble
toutefois impossible d'envisager une
ouverture pour les fêtes est bien
préférable de privilégier une
réouverture courant janvier dans de
bonnes conditions
nous nous coordonnerons sur ce point
avec nos voisins européens
la logique de toutes ces décisions est
la même au maximum limités toutes les
activités qui multiplie les
rassemblements conduisent les gens à se
rassembler sans protection dans des
lieux clos et permettre progressivement
de rouvrir les activités où l'on peut se
protéger et où les distances où les
gestes barrières sont possibles partout
sur le territoire
durant cette période donc à partir de 15
décembre
un couvre-feu de 21h à 7h du matin sera
mise en place
nous pouvons circuler librement les
soirs des 24 et 31 décembre pour
partager ces moments en famille mais les
rassemblements sur vos publics ne seront
pas tolérés durant toute cette période
vous aurez un rôle central pour notre
réussite collective
les réunions privées doivent au maximum
limité le nombre d'adultes ensemble dans
une même pièce à un même moment et nous
devons tous veiller à respecter les
règles sanitaires entre nous pour
protéger chacun
l'étape suivante sera pour le 20 janvier
en effet à cette date nous aurons le
recul suffisant au retour des fêtes de
fin d'année vous le savez il nous faut
toujours une quinzaine de jours pour
voir exactement les conséquences de la
modification de nos comportements et
donc c'est au tour de 20 janvier que 20
janvier que nous pourrons alors prendre
si cela est possible
de nouvelles décisions d'ouverture si le
nombre de contaminations demeure en
dessous de 5000 cas par jour
les salles de sport et les restaurants
pourront couvrir et le couvre feu
pourrait être décalé les lycées qui bien
souvent aujourd'hui fonctionne par de
mes classes pourrons à ce moment là être
pleinement rouvert avec la totalité des
élèves présents durant les cours quinze
jours plus tard ce sont les universités
qui courent en reprendre les cours avec
là aussi une présence physique de tous
les élèves
nous ferons ainsi le point tous les
quinze jours sur la situation sanitaire
et déciderons alors si nous pouvons
prendre des mesures supplémentaires
d'ouverture ou si au contraire il nous
faut revenir en arrière pour prévenir
tout nouvel emballement de la
propagation du virus
car nous devons tout faire pour éviter
une troisième vague tout faire pour
éviter un troisième confinement pour
cela et durant les mois qui viennent
nous avons trois outils entre nos mains
le premier c'est l'esprit de
responsabilité de tous nous ne sommes
pas vous n'êtes pas passif durant cette
crise nous avons tous un rôle à jouer
durant les congés de fin d'année
nous allons tous retrouvé nos proches
nous nous en réjouissons évidemment est
tous dans ces moments là nous sommes
tentés de baisser la garde de relâcher
la pression
mais si nous ne voulons pas subir demain
un troisième confinement nous devons
redoubler de vigilance
protégeons nos proches en particulier
les plus vulnérables portons le masque
et compris à la maison lorsque nous
sommes avec des amis ou avec des parents
il n'habite pas au quotidien avec nous
veillons à ne pas être trop nombreux à
table appliquons scrupuleusement tous
les gestes barrière se laver les mains
respectez les distances a erré toute les
heures les pièces c'est du bon sens et
de l'exigence mais chacun de nous a
entre ses mains une partie de la
solution
notre seconde outil c'est la stratégie
tester alerté protéger soigné que nous
sommes en train de réorganiser pour la
rendre beaucoup plus efficace c'est à
mes yeux l'outil le plus important dans
les semaines et les mois qui viennent
pour contrôler le virus tester nous
sommes comme vous le savez l'un des pays
européens qui testent le plus et début
janvier
aucun test ne devra mettre plus de 24
heures entre la demande de tester son
résultat ce sera vrai des tests pcr que
nous continuerons de déployer
quant aux tests antigénique qui permet
d'obtenir un résultat en moins de 30
minutes
ils seront utilisés massivement en
particulier pour les personnes qui ont
des symptômes
lorsqu'il faut dépister rapidement par
exemple dans une école ou dans une
maison de retraite
en la matière les innovations continue
de se poursuivre et permettront je
l'espère de faire encore mieux et plus
simplement
alertez nous devons dans les prochaines
semaines améliorer notre organisation
afin de casser beaucoup plus rapidement
les chaînes de contamination à la racine
en identifiant plus complètement
l'ensemble de ceux qu'on appelle les cas
contact c'est-à-dire toutes celles et
ceux qui ont été exposés à quelqu'un qui
a la cofidis mme l'application tout
senti qu vide que vous êtes prêt de 10
millions avoir téléchargé il faut
continuer est essentiel pour les
identifier utilisons la au maximum dans
les commerces
et lorsqu'ils ouvriront dans les
restaurants dans les lieux de culture
partout où nous nous rassemblons elle
est une aide précieuse pour appuyer
l'assurance maladie d'ores et déjà plus
de
mille personnes appellent chaque jour
les cas contacts et nous allons
continuer de former d'engager de
nouveaux volontaires pour encore nous
améliorer
protéger je souhaite que le gouvernement
et le parlement prévoit les conditions
pour s'assurer de l'isolément des
personnes contaminées aient compris de
manière plus contraignante
un vrai débat démocratique doit se tenir
mais si nous voulons éviter un
confinement
nous devons être plus contraignant à
l'égard de celles et ceux qui ont le
virus
ces personnes seront accompagnés sur le
plan matériel sanitaire psychologique
cette nouvelle stratégie associera outre
les services de l'état les mères et
leurs services comme les associations
concernées soigner traiter beaucoup de
progrès ont été faits et nous pouvons
nous féliciter de la mobilisation de nos
soignants nous devons continuer
d'améliorer la prise en charge et le
traitement dès le diagnostic en médecine
de ville et à l'hôpital pour réduire
encore davantage les formes graves
le troisième outil enfin qui nous
permettra de faire face au virus durant
les prochaines semaines et les prochains
mois et pour nous tous une formidable
lueur d'espoir c'est le vaccin notre
stratégie repose sur plusieurs axes ans
certains seront disponibles dès la fin
décembre début janvier et une seconde
génération arrivera au printemps
notre plan en la matière est clair
d'abord sécuriser le nombre de doses
nous l'avons fait avec l'union
européenne et la commission en achetant
auprès des producteurs en nous mettant
en capacité d'en produire en maximum en
europe et le nombre de doses étant
répartis en fonction de la population de
chaque état membre
les premiers vaccins sous réserve des
résultats des essais cliniques pourront
être administré dès la validation des
autorités sanitaires compétentes ensuite
garantir la sécurité sanitaire
un comité scientifique sera chargée d
vis de la vaccination un collectif de
citoyens sera aussi mise en place pour
associer plus largement la population et
je tiens à ce que celle ci se fasse dans
un cadre totalement transparent la
vaccination doit se faire de manière
claire transparente en partageant à
chaque étape
toutes les informations ce que nous
savons comme ceux que nous ne savons pas
et je veux aussi être clair je ne
rendrai pas la vaccination obligatoire
enfin nous allons organiser une campagne
de vaccination rapide et massive au plus
près des personnes
la haute autorité de santé présentera b
les jours à venir ses recommandations
les autorités sanitaires avec l'état les
collectivités locales définiront les
modalités pratiques du déploiement des
vaccins avec les hôpitaux les maisons de
retraite et l'ensemble des médecins de
ville
nous commencerons vraisemblablement dès
fin décembre début janvier sous réserve
de validation par les autorités
sanitaires part vacciner les personnes
les plus fragiles et donc les plus âgés
des étapes successives seront présentés
afin progressivement de permettre la
vaccination du plus grand nombre
vous le voyez le retour à la normale ne
sera donc pas pour demain mais nous
pouvons j'en ai la conviction maîtriser
l'épidémie dans la durée nous avons les
moyens
collectivement de réussir à maîtriser
puis vaincre ce virus
chacun a un rôle à jouer chacun a une
responsabilité à tenir
nous avons dans le même temps à faire
face à une crise économique et sociale
inédite
elle est la conséquence du premier
confinement et de ce que nous sommes en
train de vivre
je vous l'annoncé dès le mois de juillet
dernier la crise va vraisemblablement
encore s'aggraver
mais nous avons une réponse à apporter
nous l'avons fait dès le début en effet
depuis le premier jour nous agissons
pour les salariés avec le chômage
partiel pour les plus précaires avec des
aides ponctuelles et la prolongation des
droits en particulier pour les chômeurs
pour les entreprises et les indépendants
avec notamment les prêts garantis par
l'état
les annulations et reports de charges le
fonds de solidarité
quoi qu'il en coûte n'a pas seulement
était une formule mais bien des actes
est une réalité
nous avons renforcé cette réponse lors
de la deuxième vague et je veux ici
remercié le premier ministre et
l'ensemble du gouvernement qui en
concertant en travaillant à permet de
compléter les choses de nouvelles aides
sociales ont été décidés 150 euros
seront versés en fin de semaine aux
bénéficiaires du rsa et de l'allocation
de solidarité spécifique aux étudiants
boursiers et aux jeunes de moins de 25
ans non étudiants touchant les
allocations logement 100 euros par
enfant seront versés pour les familles
bénéficiant des apl au total 4 millions
de familles et un million trois cent
mille jeunes seront aidés les aides aux
entreprises ont été significativement en
force et en décalant les échéances des
prêts garantis par l'état
en examinant en exonérant à nouveau des
charges en augmentant à 10000 euros le
fonds de solidarité notamment pour ceux
acquis indépendants commerçants
entreprises nous avons demandé j'en ai
conscience beaucoup d'efforts beaucoup
de sacrifices alors même qu'il craignait
de perdre le fruit d'une vie de travail
ils sont tous essentiels tous à la vie
de notre nation
dès les prochains jours nous allons
encore compléter ces aides en plus des
dispositifs déjà existants les
restaurants les bars les salles de sport
les discothèques tous les établissements
qui resteront fermées administrativement
se verront verser quelle que soit leur
taille 20% de leur chiffre d'affaires de
l'année 2019 si cette option est
préférable pour eux aux 10000 euros du
fonds de solidarité
je sais les sacrifices que nous avons
demandé à beaucoup de ces entrepreneurs
je sais combien nos restaurateurs les
entrepreneurs que nous avons fermé
administrativement veulent surtout
travailler ne veulent pas être aidé ils
veulent pouvoir continuer à se lever tôt
le matin et à faire ce qui est leur
travail en même temps leur passion j'ai
conscience du sacrifice que nous leur
demandons c'est pourquoi nous allons
apporter cette aide encore exceptionnel
jusqu'au 20 janvier prochain
je l'espère date à laquelle nous
pourrons les réouvrir les saisonniers
les extras qui n'ont plus d'engagement
depuis des mois les précaires qui
travaillent et les années précédentes
mais on ne retrouve plus d'emploi les
jeunes qui n'arrivent n'a trouvé ni
emploi étudiant ni premier emploi
trouvons une réponse exceptionnelle à
leur situation
le gouvernement présentera cette réponse
dans les prochains jours le plan un
jeune une solution fera l'objet de
moyens accrus et j'invite tous les
jeunes à se renseigner sur la plate
forme prévue à cet effet toutes ces
décisions sont le fruit de larges
consultations menées par le premier
ministre et son gouvernement avec les
partenaires sociaux les élus locaux les
forces politiques
elles sont éclairées par la science il
ya certes beaucoup de choses que nous ne
maîtrisons pas mais j'assume pleinement
les décisions que je vous expose
aujourd'hui et j'assume de les prendre
pour vous pros
j'ai au maximum dans ce contexte
exceptionnel
mes chers compatriotes j'ai conscience
de vous avoir donné beaucoup de détails
ce soir mais je pense que c'était
nécessaire pour vous permettre de vous
figurer dans les prochaines semaines
comment nous allons nous organiser
si chacun nous tenons notre rôle il ya
toujours beaucoup d'incertitudes et il
nous faut garder en la matière beaucoup
d'humilité ce virus nous l'a appris
mais je ferai tout ce que je peux pour
me battre à vos côtés pour vous protéger
et réussir à maîtriser cette épidémie
cette épreuve qui dure depuis bientôt un
an est difficile pour chacun de nous et
nous ne sommes pas au bout et je ne veux
pas que nous nous laissions aller unis à
la résignation ni à la colère
je suis optimiste car toute crise
comporte une part de progrès une perte
d'espérance
regardez comme ces neuf derniers mois
nous ont permis aussi de réussir ce que
longtemps nous avions pensé impossible
nous avons su rendre notre état plus
efficace pour faire face à l'urgence
sanitaire comme économique nous avons
collectivement transformer l'hôpital
notre système de soins nous nous sommes
appuyés sur le numérique pour rapprocher
les commerçants des citoyens dans les
territoires pour continuer à travailler
à apprendre à soigner
nous avons fait preuve d'une capacité
d'innovation d'un sens de l'inventivité
qui seront décisifs pour construire le
futur et affronter les crises qui
viennent nous avons été solidaires comme
jamais nous avons aussi identifié
certaines de nos faiblesses
une organisation imparfaite trop de
bureaucratie
parfois un sens des responsabilités
inégal un manque de souveraineté parfois
aussi pour certaines de nos productions
dans les prochains mois il nous faudra à
consolider ses forces que parfois nous
ne soupçonnions pas
et corriger ces vulnérabilités que
parfois nous ne voulions pas voir
pour ce faire nous devrons nous en
remettre au savoir et à la science ne
jamais céder aux complotisme à
l'obscurantisme au relativisme nous
devrons continuer à innover à créer à
entreprendre
c'est la force de l'esprit français nous
aurons à redresser notre économie tout à
la fois en investissant en travaillant
et en étant solidaire à ce titre le plan
de relance de 100 milliards d'euros
permet de préparer l'avenir de notre
économie en créant des emplois dans des
secteurs nouveaux dans les
développements mais pour les semaines à
venir
nous devons chacune chacun à la nation
l'esprit de responsabilité
nous nous devons les uns aux autres
aussi beaucoup de bienveillance
les esprits sont parfois fatigués les
débats s'échauffent et dans cette
période
nous ne devons pas nous laisser nous
emporter tenons nous ensemble autour de
nos valeurs autour de notre histoire
dans cet attachement à notre démocratie
à notre humanisme qui demeure
aujourd'hui comme hier nous plus sûrs
atouts alors nous pourrons inventer un
nouvel avenir français mes chers
compatriotes une nouvelle fois nous
serons j'en ai la certitude au
rendez-vous des défis des semaines et
des mois qui viennent notre génération à
ensemble à vaincre cette épidémie a
affronté le terrorisme affronter la
crise climatique et celle des inégalités
aujourd'hui nous tenons ensemble demain
nous vaincrons ensemble
figure la ville et
20h26 alors vers la locution d' emmanuel
macron s'est arrêtée un petit peu de
façon abrupte une l'avion récupérés par
twitter voilà en tout cas pour ce qui
est dit ce soir par le président de la
république pour une allocution d'environ
26 minutes une allocution sur un ton
grave vous l'avez entendu qui tend en
tout cas à passer certains messages
d'espoir sur lesquels nous allons
revenir ensemble pour les prochaines
minutes puisque nous sommes en direct
ensemble sur la page principale du
figaro sur youtube mais également sur
twitch n'hésitez pas à intervenir je
vois déjà beaucoup beaucoup de messages
que ce soit dans le chat de twitch mais
également sur le chat de la page
principale du figaro et sur youtube
bah merci à vous d'être avec nous déjà
merci d'avoir passé cette allocution à
nos côtés n'hésitez pas à nous poser vos
questions à nous donner vos commentaires
nous sommes là pour vous répondre
merci en tout cas à vous je vais vous
saluer rapidement dans le chatt bonsoir
et merci d'être avec nous aux haricots
verts jupp heynckes j'ai d'abord que je
reconnais citoyens payeurs également
merci tic c'est derrière qui est souvent
là également
merci de nous avoir rejoints ce soir
merci sur twitch à vous d'être ici isaac
wells
merci pour vos commentaires et vos
réactions et enfin et bien merci
merci à tous merci à tous sur youtube
voilà pendant que je récupère un petit
peu les dernières informations
informations sur lesquelles nous allons
revenir quelles sont les grosses
annonces que le président de la
république nous a livré ce soir on va
revenir là dessus on va prendre le temps
donc si vous venez d'arriver si vous
nous rejoignez bien n'hésitez pas à nous
poser des questions sur ce que vous
auriez pu rater on va essayer de revenir
dessus je vois notamment votre question
guillaume mula sur la question des auto
écoles qui serait réouverte bas on va
essayer de répondre en tout cas un
maximum d'entre vous voilà avec le peu
de détails que nous avons a souvent le
soir de l'allocution comme ça et bien on
est on est pas en mesure de répondre à
toutes les questions puisque certaines
choses se profile à peu un petit peu
après sur les jours qui suivent mais on
va essayer de vous répondre au maximum
donc n'hésitez pas à interagir on va
voir cela ensemble pour ce ce petit
débrief que nous vous proposons de
l'autre côté et bien on vous donne
rendez-vous dans les minutes qui suivent
également avec christophe de vote qui
est spécialiste en rhétorique politique
et qui va nous donner un petit peu son
interprétation de l'allocution du
président de la république voir un petit
peu si elles sont si elle est assise
elle fut différente des précédentes ou
également s'y est bien ainsi voilà il y
avait quelque chose de particulier dans
le ton et dans la rhétorique employée
par notre président alors je vais vous
répondre je vois beaucoup de questions
sur les lycées les collèges les
universités sur la réouverture de
certaines écoles ou non bah on écoute et
on va revenir là dessus je vous propose
tout de suite un débrief assez exhaustif
de ce qui a pu se dire grâce bien aux
actualités qui sont sortis par notre
actualité du figaro sur la page
principale
je vous rappelle et peut-être que les
réseaux sociaux qui nous écoute je vous
remercie pourront vous transmettre le
lien du live qui est bien fourni et
alimenté par nos équipes
actualité du figaro voilà en tout cas ce
que l'on a appris ce soir est bien c'est
que le pic de la seconde vague est bel
et bien passé en tout cas c'est que
c'est ce que le
président de la république nous a nous a
annoncé ce soir vos efforts ont payé
l'esprit civique dont vous avez fait
preuve a été efficace voilà qui a été
annoncé alors que l'on apprend que sur
les dernières 24 heures 9155 cas ont été
déclarés de coronavirus et 458 mort à
l'hôpital ont été également
malheureusement déclaré voilà pour ces
chiffres ce que l'on sait est bien c'est
que il va y avoir bel et bien du nouveau
à partir du 28 novembre
c'est ce que l'on attendait toutefois ce
n'est pas forcément ce que l'on
attendait puisque et bien cette nouvelle
étape qui va s'ouvrir à partir du 28
novembre
ce n'est pas tout à fait un
déconfinement comme on avait pu le
connaître le 11 mai dernier lors du
premier des confinement ce sera est bien
plutôt le début d'une sorte d'allègement
ont des mesures restrictives que nous
connaissons d'ores et déjà je cite le
président de la république ce qui ne va
pas changer le confinement adopté et le
système de l'attestation restera en
vigueur il faudra continuer à travailler
ses choix chez soi à renoncer au
déplacement nécessaire voilà en tout cas
pour cela ce que l'on sait par contre
c'est un peu plus de choses sur la
réouverture de certains commerces mais
également sur l'autorisation d'une
activité physique ou en tout cas aux
deux à l'extérieur pardon et bien dans
un rayon désormais de 20 km cela va être
autorisée on pourra donc sortir pour
motif de promenade d'activité physique
pour un rayon de 20 km et pour trois
heures les activités extrascolaires en
plein air sont autorisés ainsi que
l'ouverture de commerces et services à
domicile jusqu'à 21h voilà jusque là eh
bien rien de particulièrement nouveau si
ce n'est bien l'échelle qui est mise à
disposition par ces mesures
ce que l'on sait également c'est que
dans le cadre d'un protocole sanitaire
stricte je cite les librairies les
disquaires les bibliothèques pourront
également rouvrir une annonce importante
pourrait bien beaucoup beaucoup de
commerces qui s'étaient vus
devoir fermer contrairement à certaines
grosses enseignes comme la fnac par
exemple qui est bien avait dû
restreindre l'offre qu'elle proposait
pour permettre et bien voilà de
d'accéder à tous ces produits ce que
l'on sait également est bien c'est que
la fin du confinement est elle prévue
pour le 15 décembre voilà ce qui ce qui
est annoncé à une condition toutefois si
nous sommes bien arrivés à 5000
contamination par jour affirme bien le
président de la république ce cette
deuxième étape du déconfinement en
version 2 j'ose dire et bien commencera
donc le 15 décembre
voilà un nouveau cap que l'on pourra
atteindre si comme je le disais je le
répète nous sommes bien arrivés à 5000
contamination par jour voilà donc c'est
ce que nous avons appris
nous pourrons donc se déplacer nous
déplacer pardon sans autorisation y
compris entre régions pour passer noël
en famille ça c'était aussi l'une des
grosses annonces que l'on attendait
pourrait bien prévoir un petit peu les
vacances à venir et surtout cette
période importante de noël dans notre
société
il faudra toutefois et bien limiter au
maximum les déplacements inutiles
voilà ce que l'on sait toutefois pour en
tout cas l'ouverture de certains
commerces 1 je voulais expliquer par
exemple les disquaires qui pourront
rouvrir et bien les salles de cinémas
les théâtres et musées ne pourront pas
ouvrir ça c'est ce que l'on apprend les
grands rassemblements seront toujours
fermé les parcs d'attractions également
les bars restaurants et les discothèques
tout à fait bien resteront fermés
également voilà ce que l'on sait
toutefois par contre c'est que et bien
les sports d'hiver eux pourront bien
rouvrir toutefois un peu plus tard que
prévu
il ne sera pas possible d'aller aux
sports d'hiver pour les vacances de noël
toutefois on apprend que les sports
d'hiver pourrait rouvrir courant janvier
selon le président de la république
nous allons nous orienter tout de suite
vers christophe
devenu spécialiste en rhétorique
politique qu'est ce que vous nous
entendez alors je vais de ce pas branché
mon petit micro pour pouvoir vous
entendre également alors je vais essayer
up de vous transmettre ce sont voilà un
petit moment technique
je vous donne rendez vous tout de suite
n'hésitez pas à rester avec nous alors
hop alors nous allons rejoindre
christophe gallaz pour maman nous ne
nous entendons pas mais cela ne va pas
tarder voilà n'hésitez pas si vous avez
en tout cas des questions si vous
souhaitez qu'on aborde certains points
que nous avions que nous aurions
peut-être raté sur cette ses allocutions
on va revenir plus en détail sur ce que
nous avons pu bien apprendre
alors je vous donne rendez-vous dans
quelques secondes seulement le temps
pour moi de me brancher et on va faire
un petit débrief qui est de la
rhétorique pour voilà voir un petit peu
comment cela s'est passé du côté de
l'elysée je vous dis à tout de suite
dans quelques secondes juste
où
[Musique]
la réponse est non
oui
voilà figure là ils vont se retrouve en
direct après cette petite interruption
technique pour se brancher en direct
avec christophe de bugs de spécialistes
en rhétorique politique
vous avez suivi bien en même temps que
nous cette allocution du président de la
république avant même d'aborder la
locution en elle-même
eh bien on peut dire qu'on était dans
une période un petit peu tendu avec
beaucoup beaucoup d'enjeux comment à
votre avis a pu être préparé cette
allocution par le président de la
république avait coûté visiblement il ya
eu un très long conseil de défense ce
matin qu'elle y aurait trois heures et
puis je pense qu'ensuite il a dû
regarder les derniers chiffres et puis
enregistrer puis je me suis mis
allocution enregistrée d'après ce que je
comprends donc c'est un mois je veux
dire c'est un exercice difficile mais en
quelque sorte un exercice un peu attendu
puisque le président avait donné rendez
vous le symposium intervention sur le
sujet donc c'est bien c'était le grand
jour attendu
d'ailleurs où je sais pas je n'ai pas
encore eu le le nombre de d'auditeurs
mais je pense qu'on doit être créée ou
il ya un effet il y avait un effet
d'attentes entretenue par les médias
notamment par vous depuis quand même
plusieurs jours et heures de parole
libératrice qui était attendu oui tout à
fait un puits ben voilà il faut dire en
plus que les mesures du gouvernement
était particulièrement observée cette
semaine après un rassemblement à c'est
important ça me dit au sujet de la loi
de sécurité globale c'est vrai qu'on est
dans un espèce de moments clés entre eux
les enjeux de la crise sanitaire et des
enjeux sociaux que nous voyons voilà en
tout cas pour bien cette préparation
vous qui avez suivi cette allocution où
comme nous tous et comme vous le disiez
très attendu en disant nous sommes très
nombreux que ce soit sur la page
principale du figaro sur youtube mais
également sur twitter bien qu'est ce que
vous en avez pensé puisque c'est quand
même une
une allocution assez importante dans le
sens où elle annonce bien une nouvelle
étape celle d'un déconfinement nouvelle
version j'ose dire mais d'abord il faut
quand même s'interroger sur le fait que
justement on froide
là c'est parce que c'est quand même prêt
à les organiser dans cette situation
d'attenté
il faut quand même commencé par
souligner le fait quelque chose d'un peu
étonnant et d'ahmed un peu anormal
finalement dans une démocratie que nous
soyons tous suspendus aux lèvres
présidentielle depuis des jours pour
entendre le président revenir sur des
mesures qu'il a lui-même prise
donc nous avons attendu le 2 ça vous que
confinement la mésentente nous attendons
nous entendons par dont nous attendons
et nous entendons de sa bouche non pas
le des compliments ticket vous avez vu
qu'il n'avait pas voulu employer
l'expression mais un allègement du
confinement donc il ya quand même un
système devrait quand même commencer par
la sem quand même de de conditionnement
de stop and go au niveau rhétorique
confinement à confinement allégé qui est
quand même un peu surprenant si on veut
bien se mettre en dehors de ce jeu dans
lequel nous sommes tous pris c'est un
premier point mais voilà nous y sommes
comme une [ __ ] et maintenant est ce que
le jeu et qui a joué c'était un discours
qu'il figure parmi les bons discours d'
emmanuel macron avec toujours évidemment
sept petits défauts ce péché mignon qui
d'être toujours un peu long on est
toujours apte à près de 30 minutes je
crois qu emmanuel macron le mémoire
n'arrive jamais à faire en dessous de 1
minute et là on voit bien dans ce
discours que la substance de ce discours
pouvait être aisément résumé en 15
minutes mais après c'est dans sa session
style rhétorique d'être un petit peu
long mais sur le fond le ton était bon
il a trouvé un temps que j'ai trouvé
juste par rapport à d'autres discours
c'est à dire un ton il n'était ni trop
solennel niekro comment dirais-je émotif
comme il le fait parfois
d'un ton juste donc de ce côté là
c'était cd c'était bien ça éclaire aussi
dans le contenu
à peu près en tout cas même s'il y aura
beaucoup s'interroger sur le timing
exact des mesures mais enfin il a le cap
comme il l'avait dit et tracer des
étapes pour atteindre ce cap sont là
donc il y a du grain à moudre
voilà ça c'est le première impression je
dirais plutôt positive
mais encore une fois dans un système est
dans une situation rhétorique c'est à
dire d'un locuteur et des récepteurs que
nous sommes qu'il faut interroger quand
même au départ parce qu'elle est un peu
surprenante un peu surprenante et j'ai
envie de dire ce mandat d' emmanuel
macron est quand même en ce qui concerne
la rhétorique votre votre domaine est
quand même assez particulier dans le
sens où les allocutions se multiplient
on commence à m habituer
peut-être parfois un peu lassé par la
multiplication de ces habitations qui
sont malgré tout nécessaire pour avoir
les grandes mesures
comment vous l'observez vous cette
multiplication d'allocutions est-ce
qu'elle va marquer son temps est ce
qu'elle va marquer l'histoire politique
là je vais pas tout à fait d'accord avec
vous parce que si vous regardez bien par
rapport à la premier confirmant là le
président est moins intervenu depuis
quelques temps il n'est pas intervenu
depuis le mois sur le sujet en tout cas
donc non il essaye n'ont pas de rares et
c'est sa parole ce serait peut-être
demander mais en tout cas ils essaient
de l'espace y est c'est une loi de la
rhétorique bien connu surtout quand on a
une parole importante faut l'économiser
donc on peut pas dire qu'il l'a
multiplient et je crois d'ailleurs qu'il
fait bien de tous plus la multiplier
cela dit beaucoup de choses subi ces
sacs à mon avis nous voulons vous
admettrez qu'un ministre de la santé ou
un premier ministre aurait plus qu'à des
beaucoup de détails qu'il a donnée sur
les calendriers le type de commerce etc
vous pouvez on pourrait concevoir une
communication faite un peu différemment
voilà mais ça bon c'est un peu le
système de la 5ème très accentuée par le
quinquennat est encore plus accentuée
par le président actuel qui
concentré sur cinq seules paroles il
s'expose du coup évidemment ils
s'exposent et politiquement c'est très
clair et là il faut mesurer on saura
très vite l'impact alors la ja il ya
évidemment des choses qui vous plaire
c'est encore une fois comme on est très
serré les moindres des serments a évolué
favorablement et ça c'est la ville comme
conditionnement public mais il ya quand
même des questions qui restent
inquiétantes vous roulez les restaurants
merci finalement une attente de deux
mois il aurait proposé fils aurait
imposé y compris la période des fêtes
qui pour eux évidemment décisif
donc ce n'est quand même pas que des
bonnes nouvelles d'autant qu'il ya une
chose qui m'a étonné de la faudra
débriefer davantage ce qui m'a étonné
c'est qu'il y avait dans le contenu du
discours à double critère c'est à dire
un nombre de réanimation et de
contamination il sait à 5000 s'il nous
faut y à bien et à 2500 et en même temps
des dates parce qu'on n'arrive pas à
bien savoir c'est si les choses
s'améliorent plus vitesse que les dates
et les délais seront raccourcis et là je
ne sais pas si c'est moi qui vous
interroge voyez jeu pour que là il y
avait une ambiguïté je trouve qu'il
aurait pu laisser une porte ouverte en
disant si ça va beaucoup mieux mais on
pourra accélérer calendrier je n'ai pas
entendu mais peut-être que je me trompe
la pression des dates sont un peu fixé
dans dans le bronze
et ça ça risque d'être un peu décevant
surtout si les choses s'améliorent plus
vite que prévu on est toujours dans un
champ lexical guerrier un jour se
souvient de cette annonce et de cette
citation nous sommes en guerre lors du
premier confinement les derniers mots
que le président de la république a dit
eh bien aujourd'hui nous tenons ensemble
demain nous vaincrons ensemble c'est
intéressant toujours cette rhétorique
guerrière qui est toujours employée de
très nombreux mois après premier
confinement christophe oui mais la
guerre c'est dans le même sens ce
conseil de défense
une chose
devrait simple et en fait comme si elle
était un haut conseil de santé publique
non je pense que c'est une stratégie
bien connu la guerre ça ça mobilise le
pas plaint donc que mes foraine ne
jamais oublier que ça restait métaphore
parce que le virus n'est pas un ennemi
au sens traditionnel du terme la france
que vous avez à d'autres ennemis et
d'autres bières qui sont véritablement
du centre gay il s'agit ici d'une
épidémie mais avant le président étant
rentré dans sa dans cette métaphore il a
tendance comme on dit a filé la
métaphore et ça c'est pas forcément
c'est pas forcément bête parce que ça
lui donnera le crédit de la continuité
en effet andy rabbins des faits il a
utilisé depuis le premier jour de même
qu'il a rappelé le quoi qu'il en coûte
donc il assume et ça quand on est le
chef assume et toujours bien perçu un
grand merci pour bien ces conclusions
christ de vote dont vous retrouve
régulièrement sur figaro life pour bien
débriefé des grands annonce vous
rappelle que vous êtes spécialiste en
rhétorique politique
moi je vous remercie beaucoup je
souhaite une très bonne soirée
merci à vous à bientôt davantage d'eau
voilà pour cette partie et bien
debriefing en ce qui concerne la
rhétorique politique avec christophe de
vote qu'on a pu contacter on l'en
remercie
nous sommes toujours ensemble pour
répondre à vos questions je sais que
vous avez beaucoup de questions sur les
écoles les collèges les lycées
eh ben je vais y répondre de ce pain je
vais pouvoir comme cela vous répondre
sur youtube
merci en tout cas à tous d'être toujours
avec nous m'ont soir l'iem sur internet
sur twitch merci
vous d'être avec nous de lucifer 0,1
également sur twitch merci également sur
la page principale du figaro à pablo
mort à la web open web aux frênes
j'espère ne pas écorcher votre monde
georges arbitres génial c'est toujours
la peur voilà donc je vais vous faire un
conditionneur du figaro et alors là je
reviens mais bonjour apparaîtra
également sur body très nombreux et pour
bien vous répondre un prélèvement sur la
plus grosse c'est la question des
collèges lycées et passionnant et bien
sachez que nous avons fait des
événements passés sous la dent que l'on
a ainsi rencontré mon âge et bien sûr
lanciers dans l'es10 avec pour première
course a présenté la partie des biens
février voilà ce que ce sera le cas
1/3 topple sanitaire s'appliquer à ce
que l'on sait également
sachez bien couvrir la glisse et voilà
ce qu'on va le prendre ici avec une
présence sur les élèves
c'est ce que l'on apprend ce soir alors
feu est bien le président avait annoncé
à la fin octobre a su saisir sur les
voilà qui sait déjà que vous attendez le
recul il y aura du cap qu'un seul
message et c'est bien suivi de février
c'est à nourrir en ce qui concerne le
trafic ce qui paraît bien ça aussi nous
avons eu c'est les et style puisque vous
aviez peut-être vu dans la semaine c'est
l'anti très bien ce que l'on sait c'est
que l'équipe de tournage dès ce week-end
avec la réouverture g lieux de culte si
bien organiser des offices
cette fois nous avons bien des
déclarations qui nous provient ce sens
reste encore là il a pu avoir
l'évêque de gap est qui qui déniche unis
dans cette décision
il pensait à 30 personnes voilà on parle
bien ces dernières minutes on a voulu
briser leur épisode plusieurs nous
première étape ce que blaise est bel et
bien c'est que les joueuses reprendrait
des petits feux à la normale à partir 15
des personnes contaminées soit bien
d'arriver à saint denis a pris on a
appris également sports d'hiver alors je
vois que nous avons un petit problème
dessus en réserve mais je crois que la
voilà vous m'entendrez mieux merci à
pierre pilet qui m'a aidé un petit peu à
y voir plus clair je n'avais pas vu cela
merci beaucoup de nous avoir prévenus là
vous iriez mieux m'entendre j'espère que
vous n'avez pas raté en tout cas ce que
j'ai pu bien vous expliquer de toute
façon on est là pour répondre à vos
questions n'hésitez pas à n'hésitez pas
à nous nous nous reposer vos questions
je vois notamment beaucoup de questions
sur les lycées sur les collèges et les
écoles
et bien voilà en tout cas merci pour
pour cette technique je vois beaucoup de
réactions sur
sur youtube notamment voilà alors en ce
qui concerne les écoles les lycées
sachez que nous l'avons appris je vais
le répéter si jamais ce n'était pas très
clair puisqu'il y avait un petit
doublons sont j'en suis désolé c'est moi
qui fais la technique aussi en plus de
cette présentation
voilà ce que nous avons appris c'est que
les lycées allait reprendre en fit en
présentiel et non plus seulement en
visio ça ce sera pour la fin du mois de
janvier et début du mois de février
début du mois de février qui sera
marquée également par une réouverture
des universités
deux semaines après les lycées et bien
les universités et les écoles pourront
ouvrir à partir et bien de là et
reprendre des cours avec une présence
physique
voilà qui répond en tout cas beaucoup de
votre question en ce qui concerne le
milieu de la culture et notamment celui
des grands événements festifs en lieu
clos
eh bien ils sont évidemment toujours
annulés et pour moment ne seront pas
encore autorisé ils resteront interdits
ce que l'on a appris ce soir avec par
exemple et bien les événements culturels
mais également les parcs d'attraction ou
les parcs d'exposition ce que l'on sait
également c'est que bien le couvre-feu
va lui se maintenir
que ce soit à partir du 15 décembre où
le couvre-feu sera toujours de 21h à 7h
du matin mais également et bien il sera
très probablement même s'il sera allégé
mais très probablement sera maintenu au
delà du 15 janvier avec certes des
horaires moins strictes mais cela
dépendra là aussi du nombre de
contaminations quotidienne voilà ce que
l'on a appris ce soir pour cette
allocution
bonsoir à vous qui nous suivez sur
twitter je vais vous salut et merci à
eux que 25 de travail que nous merci
jean lassalle gaming très joli nom il y
à 7 minutes qui nous a follow merci
également à micheline liam sur internet
qui nous a suivis tout à l'heure de
lucifer 0 1 merci du faux l'on vous
on vous remercie d'être là avec nous ce
soir on a beaucoup de questions aussi
sur les auto-écoles je vois sur youtube
où par exemple vous bilel de grâce vous
nous dites ouvrez les auto-écoles sinon
ça va être pire en 2021 en termes
d'attentes unis va ya voir oui c'est
vrai beaucoup de coups de monde qui va
se presser et qui va faire la queue pour
et bien pour pouvoir passer les
différents examens
nous n'avons pas eu en tout cas de
précision en ce qui concerne les auto
écoles
ce que l'on sait c'est que le présentiel
sera ouvert pour les études supérieures
donc les lycées les universités et les
grandes écoles
toutefois en ce qui concerne les
auto-écoles nous n'avons pas eu de
précisions supplémentaires lors de sd
vous le demande et si les collèges sont
fermés et bien dans les collèges sont
toujours ouverts et vont le rester
voilà ce qui concerne les écoles
primaires également donc voilà qui vous
répond vous êtes bel et bien obligés d'y
retourner
voilà pour ses nombreuses questions cela
vous répondre notamment à vous loue nous
mourrons pour les collèges voilà ce que
nous avons appris également est bien
c'est que la vague de la vaccination
c'est l'un des points importants de ces
dernières semaines avec l'annoncé par
certains laboratoires d'un vaccin sûr à
plus de 90%
et bien c'est que la vaccination devra
se faire de manière claire et
transparente là je cite le président
partageant les informations à chaque
étape la campagne de vaccination
importante un com com comme élément là
mais la campagne de vaccination devra
commencer
selon ce que nous dit le président de la
république à partir de la fin du mois de
décembre début du mois de janvier sous
réserve de validation par les autorités
sanitaires pour vacciner les personnes
fragiles l'âge le site et donc les plus
âgés toutefois cette vaccination ne sera
pas obligatoire c'est ce que l'on a
appris également
emmanuel macron un kia et bien donner
plus de détails sur cette vaccination
contre le coc vide 19 qui ne sera pas
obligatoire en france voilà pour ces
points un peu plus précis je vous
remercie d'être avec nous je vais
prendre une dernière salve de questions
pour voir si il y aurait certains points
que je n'aurais pas abordé comme par
exemple celui du télétravail pour vous
il ya une josselin qui nous demandait
quid du télétravail est ce qu'on
continue jusqu'à fin décembre et bien
techniquement on continuera jusqu'au 15
décembre c'est en tout cas ce qu'a
demandé le président de la république
puisque bien je vois là si nous sommes
arrivés au point symbolique de 5000
contamination par jour est bien là il y
aurait un allègement du confinement à
partir du 15 décembre
et donc du télétravail mais pour moment
là la règle en vigueur reste toujours le
confinement et le télétravail en ce qui
concerne ces questions voilà pour ces
questions en ce qui concerne le vaccin
est bien d'abord à pâques a levé nous
demander le prix du vaccin même un pur
moment peut encore d'annonce là dessus
on se bat on restera connecter avec vous
pour vous offrir plus de 2 d'information
sur ce sujet qui sera essentiel pour la
sortie de crise sanitaire pour chaque
société pour tous les pays voilà
merci à vous d'être avec nous également
sur la page principale du figaro diego
roue breizh vous demandez à partir de
quelle heure pouvez vous faire de
l'exercice et bien techniquement entre
les heures de couvre feu donc entre 21h
et 7h et vous vous être impossible a en
tout cas en tout cas entre 7 heures et
21 heures là je pense que vous serez
tout à fait libre de faire de l'exercice
et on l'a appris donc le rayon dans
lequel vous pourrez faire de l'exercice
et a été largement augmenté 1 puisque
nous sommes passés d'un rayon d'un
kilomètre a plu à près de 20 km avec 6
également une durée de deux sorties de
trois heures voilà qui nous apporte un
peu plus de répondre voilà j'essaye de
suivre aussi vos questions qui
continuent de défiler vous êtes nombreux
avec nous ce soir et ça fait plaisir au
minium vous ne demandez si le président
a parlé du 20 janvier
est ce lié au passage de trump à bail
donne la date de passation entre les
deux présidents américains alors je ne
ne peux pas vous donner plus de détails
il faudrait demander à des des sources
proches du gouvernement et du conseil de
défense qui a été menée par le président
de la république mais en tout cas ce
qu'ils ont sont conscients on en croit
les déclarations du président les dates
qui ont été annoncées sont bel et bien
lié plutôt à des causes sanitaire que
diplomatique avec l'international et son
homologue américain voilà en tout cas
qui répond à vos questions n'hésitez pas
à nous retrouver henry plaire que ce
soit sur fear alive vous pourrez
retrouver ces annonces en direct vous
pourrez également retrouver en direct et
henry en replay pardon c'est
c'est réponse que nous avons pu vous
apporter alors là je vois que vous nous
rejoignez bonsoir esma altin gad sur
youtube ou encore alex merle vous me
demander quand est-ce que nous serons
des confiné et bien ne seront dès
confiné à partir techniquement du 15
décembre mais pas tout à faire déjà ce
sera une condition que nous soyons à au
cap symbolique de 5000 contamination par
jour et cela aussi est bien sera mis sur
plusieurs étapes
donc c'est la voie la première étape de
déconfinement en partie à partir du 15
décembre c'est ce que nous apprenons ce
soir aussi beaucoup de questions sur la
couverture notamment des coiffeurs bien
sachez que beaucoup de commerces
pourront rouvrir à partir du 15 décembre
toutefois et à partir même de d'être un
peu plus tôt toutefois les restaurants
eux ne resteront fermés les discothèques
également et certains commerces comme
par exemple les cinémas vont devoir
également restés confinés et donc ne
pourrons rouvrir
c'est ce que nous avons appris ce soir
ce que l'on sait également c'est qu'une
exception au couvre-feu qui va se
maintenir lui même au courant du mois de
décembre est bien une exception sur la
fête le soir de noël et le soir du
nouvel an toutefois les rassemblements
sur la voie publique
eux seront interdits voilà vous pourrez
rejoindre vos amis ou vos familles
toutefois vous ne pourrez pas célébrer
comme il en est coutume en ces périodes
de fêtes
ce que l'on sait donc c'est que les
restaurants cafés et salles de sport
seront autorisés à ouvrir m'excuse
seulement à partir du 20 janvier va donc
falloir être patient pour retrouver ses
commerces et il va falloir aussi pour
ses commerces et bien qu'ils résistent
encore à ses difficultés économiques qui
s'abattent sur eux depuis le premier
confinement que nous avons connu voilà
il est temps pour moi de vous
de vous quitter après cette allocution
importante du président de la république
ça a commencé il ya près d'une heure il
est désormais 21h01
merci beaucoup qui rona pour votre
message sur twitter merci d'être avec
nous merci pwned assure twitch également
pour le follow merci à eux que 25e sur
internet
merci à vous d'avoir suivi sur twitter
merci sur youtube à tonton david faiseur
tailleur 10 valentin ermias
sortilège guyane dont linda jean-louis
merci d'ailleurs valente à la lumière de
votre gentil message sur youtube ça fait
très plaisir
je dis ça avec beaucoup d'ironie merci
en tout cas
tonton david singer je vous ai déjà
cités ni tiga iris voilà en tout cas
pour vous répondre dany en ce qui
concerne les auto écoles pour le moment
pas d'informations ce que je vous
conseille de faire c'est de contacter
votre auto écoles dans les jours qui
suivent pour avoir un peu plus
d'informations de leur côté puisque ce
sera du cas par cas il va falloir être
patient également pour cela merci enfin
sur la page principale du figaro à au
minium diego bresse pablo morales a ouai
bof run et djar djar bing ce je vous
souhaite à tous une très bonne soirée et
je vous dis à très vite sur figaro live